Welcome back.
I hope you were able to get your support vector classifier working, but
in case you need a little nudge, let me show you what I did.
So, starting from the starter code,
there's only actually two lines of code that I need to add.
The first one is that I have to fit my classifier, and
I have to fit it on the training table.
I have to fit it on the training data, so
that means passing features_train, and labels_train to my fit function.
Then, the second thing is making a list of predictions.
So, I store to a list named pred, and that's just
the familiar predict function that we've seen with the Naive Bayes classifier.
Remember, when you're making predictions,
you're only going to be passing one set of information, now, the features.
Because the labels are what you're trying to predict.
And also, of course,
you want to do it on the test dataset, not on the training dataset.
So, with two lines like this you should be able to get your SVM up and running.